omit the ruble the noise of Dicker's is
broken by howls of sadness as rescue
workers retrieved the dead that bereaved
are left to grapple with homes and lives
ruined in remote support Sahab in the
worst-hit area buildings have been
destroyed with much of the town laid
waste the frantic search for the living
is now turning into a recovery effort
for the injured survivors the town's
only hospital is not an option
with only makeshift eight facilities and
a shortage of vital supplies hundreds
have been ferried halfway across the
country to the capital Tehran
there was nothing where we came from no
electricity no water I'm in a bad way I
was in a hospital for 18 hours across
the border in Iraq people are trying to
return to normal darbandi Khan bore the
brunt of the damage here the building
was flattened by the earthquake the
rubble collapsed on a family of seven we
only managed to rescue five of them the
other two were killed the disaster has
left an estimated 70,000 people homeless
neighboring countries have been
answering the call for help Turkey has
set humanitarian assistance along with
3,000 tents and ten thousand beds